everything's under control
situation normal won't happen ahead
slight weapons malfunction but
everything's perfectly all right now
we're fine we're all fine here now thank
you
hey youtubers is Charlie you may have
heard that the Star Wars Han Solo movie
just fired its directors Lucasfilm
literally said you're out with three
weeks to go on the film so I'll explain
what's going on if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's going to be a bunch
of Star Wars dropping in the next month
because of d23 but if you didn't think
they were going to be bringing some
really awesome footage then based on the
debacle that happened yesterday they're
going to try and do everything they can
to make you forget that something bad
just happened and you're worried about a
Star Wars movie now people are always
worried about Star Wars movies for
really stupid reasons but if you don't
know what happened
Phil Lord and Chris Miller - really
idiosyncratic but really amazing writer
directors were hired to do the Han Solo
movie they announced the movie last year
they announced the cast everything
seemed good they started shooting
earlier this year so they've been
shooting all year up to this point they
had about three weeks left to go
principal photography in all of sudden
boom it just blows up in their face
they're outright fired Lucasfilm and
Kathleen Kennedy announced a statement
they announced a statement that our
creative visions have not aligned with
our partners so we're choosing to part
ways most of you instantly realized that
that's the nice way of saying that
somebody quit or somebody got fired
big-time in the biggest surprise isn't
so much that people got fired people get
fired from movies all the time people
get fired from the Star Wars franchise
all the time remember when josh trank
was going to do rogue one right after
Fantastic Four came out they just
mysteriously announced that they parted
ways with him before they started
shooting rogue one Gareth Edwards came
on but the key reason that people are
citing from behind the scenes and this
is all anecdotal because people are
saying sources revealed behind the
scenes tension between Lucasfilm
Kathleen Kennedy Lawrence Kasdan who's
another big producer in the Star Wars
universe in the directors
so apparently Kathleen Kennedy and the
other Star Wars people like the
corporate people felt like the movie
Lord and middle
we're making wasn't Star Wars II enough
so I know that sounds weird but you have
to remember that these are the people
most known for doing the lego movie for
doing 21 22 Jump Street as well as a lot
of weird TV projects like Last Man
Standing so they do a lot of comedy they
do a lot of weird idiosyncratic things
so there's a lot of conjecture about
what was happening on set
but suffice to say the Star Wars people
were not happy with what was happening
in the footage that they were seeing so
they wanted to do a bunch of reshoots
but the directors stuck their foot in
the ground and say hey this is our movie
you said that we would have control
we're going to make the movie that you
hired us to make in the problem with
that is that Star Wars the other big
franchises like Marvel Kevin Feige they
don't like it when directors do stuff
like that like it's always good to stand
your ground patty Jenkins had to stand
her ground to get that no man's land
scene for Wonder Woman left in the film
the Warner Brothers people wanted to
pull that out of the film they're like
you don't need that it's pointless but
it turned out to be one of the best
parts of the film so sometimes directors
standing their ground when Studios want
to cut big things out of the movie is
good but apparently on the Han Solo set
this was the straw that broke the
camel's back in their personalities
we're clashing the whole time from day
one it was just not a good marriage of
directors in studio so what probably
happened is the Kathleen Kennedy the
studio people wanted to bring in a
director who would finish the project
and make it look the way they wanted it
to look rather than bring them a really
good film that wasn't necessarily what
they thought of is a Star Wars film so
you have the directors that are trying
to uphold their create a vision that
they felt like they were hired to do and
you have the studio that's trying to
protect it's multi-billion dollar
franchise we don't want a quirky Han
Solo movie we want a han Solo movie that
everybody's going to like and you can
understand why a studio would want that
even though in this situation I think
the directors were right to stand up for
their vision even if it wasn't going to
be a traditional Star Wars film
sometimes you get really interesting
things when you pick really interesting
Directors in the criticism that most
people are labeling on Lucasfilm is that
if you hired idiosyncratic directors
then why were you so surprised when they
gave you that kind of movie but that's
just the reality of studio filmmaking it
happened to Edgar Wright on the ant-man
movie
hee hee quit the movie after Kevin Feige
brought in a bunch of other writers to
change a bunch of scenes change his
script in Edgar Wright said this isn't a
movie that I made anymore you've changed
it so much that it isn't something that
I want to put my name on so that was
different he did not get fired from
ant-man he chose to leave
they say that Phil Lord and Chris Miller
didn't want to leave the Han Solo movie
they were forcibly kicked out like boom
by the seat-of-the-pants they've since
released some more statements where
they're like yeah we hate to use that
term creative differences but in this
instance is actually pretty accurate we
were not making the movie they wanted us
to make we had something different in
mind
ultimately they need to protect their
brand so it's totally understandable
they got fired junkie XL just got fired
from the Justice League movie he was
going to score it now they're bringing
in Danny Elfman so people get fired from
big hundred and fifty million dollar
franchise movies all the time when that
much money is on the line Studios get
very paranoid but now there's three
weeks left a principal photography they
have all the reshoots that they want to
do in addition to that so Kathleen
Kennedy says we'll announce a new
director very soon so that means in the
next week or so right now the leading
candidate they're talking about is Ron
Howard so you can see what they're doing
they're bringing in somebody who has a
lot of experience with big franchises
who will do what the studio says like
you're being brought in to clean up a
mess please clean it up in the way that
we asked you to and be on your way
what's going to happen next is is
they'll shut production down for a
couple weeks while the new director
comes in figures out what stuff they
already have what they need to reshoot
in how they need to re-edit the film
because they've been shooting all year
so they've been editing as they go so
just like Edgar Wright's ant-man got
completely changed but there were like a
few little bits of it that they left in
there the same thing will probably
happen with Han Solo there'll be a lot
of phil lord chris miller stuff in there
but it won't look anything like the
original film that they'd intended to
make silver lining though now that they
got fired from Star Wars Lord and Miller
are free to come back to the flash movie
which has had problems finding writers
and directors they originally turned out
a draft of that script they were on
board to do the movie then they got
hired to do Star Wars so they're like
okay Star Wars
definitely happening tomorrow we want to
do a Star Wars movie turns out didn't
end up going so well so now maybe
they'll come back to the flash movie so
who knows the Justice League Joss Whedon
situation is a little bit different
circumstances weren't that dire they
were getting ready to do their reshoots
so Zack Snyder had to leave for family
reasons Joss Whedon was brought in to
sort of just uh sure it right over the
finish line just a few more scenes to
collaborate on and then the editing and
that's it like the film was pretty much
already done when Joss Whedon came in
so because d23 is happening in a couple
weeks it's not even that far off it's
happening in the middle of July they're
going to be dropping a whole bunch of
Disney related things like Marvel
trailers Star Wars trailers they are
probably going to try and crank out
something really awesome so that you
forget all about this stuff
think about how scary it would be for
Star Wars if they turned out a han Solo
movie that fans didn't like it would be
a bloodbath there are already people
that are worried about episode 9 because
Colin Trevorrow who's directing it just
turned out a film called book of Henry
it was terribly received people thought
it was hot garbage so now they're like
oh my god what does this mean about
Episode nine just to be clear I don't
think there's any reason to be worried
about Episode nine if they're this
hardcore about a spinoff Han Solo movie
think about how hardcore Lucasfilm is
about their saga films but let me know
what you guys think about this I think
it's just so shocking because it's such
a high-profile brand and we're heading
into Episode eight it's literally a
couple months away but what's going to
happen next is they'll be some more Game
of Thrones they announced a watchman TV
series is being developed at HBO for the
next couple years we probably won't see
it till 2019 at least and they just
announced a whole bunch more stuff about
the spider-verse and the spider-man
franchise we got a whole bunch of stuff
to talk about so I'll try and post
everything as fast as possible while you
wait for that click here to rewatch the
Game of Thrones trailer I just posted
and you can click here for all my Star
Wars videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you